Let's go next to our caller from the 903 area
code.
Who's calling today from nine one three.
Hi David.
Can you hear me?
Yeah.
Who's this?
Uh, this is Brendan.
I'm calling from a Kansas City, Kansas.
Hey, Brendan, what's going on?
Um, I was wondering what your thoughts are
on Bernie Sanders calling himself a democratic
socialist when that's clearly not.
Who's a real stance on his political ideology?
He's obviously a social democrat.
He doesn't want to destroy capitalism.
I just, I have no idea why he wants to call
himself that.
I get that he wants to, you know, lessen the
negativity of socialism, but at the same time,
that's just totally wrong.
I don't
totally agree.
I don't know why I've two or three videos
on this.
Bernie Sanders should stop saying Democratic
Socialism.
And I know that there are the a players of
semantic games who will say, David, it democratic
socialism.
It just means social democracy now.
And that's what Bernie's talking about.
It's, he's doing himself and the movement
a disservice.
The policies he's running on in the policies
he's advocating are not socialist policies.
They are social democracy policies.
And I don't know why he keeps doing it.
And I've been saying for years that he shouldn't
be doing it.
And I've not gotten a single email from people.
That has changed my mind.
The one argument people write in with is David,
he's just, he's changed the words Democratic
Socialism means social democracy now.
And if that's the case, I think it's extremely
problematic because it's just so confusing
and it allows the right to continue to Straw
man the left as socialist when almost all
of our policies that are being seriously discussed,
our social democracy policies.
I think it's a terrible thing and you should
stop.
Yeah, I completely agree with you.
Um, thanks for taking my call and give your
opinion on them.
My pleasure at Brendan.
Great to hear from you from Kansas City.
Uh, hope to hear from you again.